hi
i'm back
now
without my two bearded companions so now
we can
speak alone without them knowing what
we're saying
i was i was planning on doing a live
stream eventually uh and you know i was
kind of in that mode after just getting
off the
joint
live stream that i did with justin and
zebi so i thought i might as well just
do a solo thing for a few minutes now hi
everyone hi rich and
hello
hello hello hello hello nice to see you
all
so i just hang out with you
for a little while alaikum salaam
um hope you're all doing well
i assume
i mean the audio is always a bit low i
don't know what to do about that the the
the microphone is cranked essentially
[Music]
yeah i can't go any higher
hope some of you joined us me and zevi
and justin
for our
the live stream we did together just a
few minutes ago
on uh justin's channel esoterica that
was a lot of fun
sorry if we didn't get to all of your
questions of course there's a limited
amount of
of time and of course a lot of those
questions were quite complex so
it took
you know it
they all deserved to be talked about for
for for a long
longer than just
short simple answers right
um
i am not edward snowden actually no
how are you all doing
good
one one what i didn't realize that there
is
seems to be a
philosophical metaphysical component or
aspect to the title of this live stream
but i guess it is you can interpret the
title as you wish either as simply uh a
reference to the fact that i i'm you
know zebby and justin aren't here
anymore or
it could be a
theological statement
i'm doing fine thank you
feel free to ask me some questions i
don't have any tea today
mono so okay so the
you know
the sound's gonna have to do for now
what are your thoughts on sad guru just
for fun
asks me what are your thoughts on
saturday i've seen some of his videos
i'm not offended by anything he has said
in those videos that i've seen i think
he seems to know
his stuff i guess
but i really haven't seen enough to
to make a
statement or have a an informed opinion
about that he seems
seems like a
like a
knowledgeable guy with with charisma
so why don't i have tea today well i had
tea
i've had a bunch of coffee today sadly
because i i was there was a lot of stuff
at work and i had tea earlier too so i
just feel like i shouldn't be drinking
too much
caffeine before i go to bed essentially
xavi is here
uh yes
it's a marathon
i'm gonna go
all night
thank you zevi again for the wonderful
stream we did that was
a lot of fun a lot of fun
will i do a video on
frederic nietzsche
uh maybe i mean
there are there is a channel called
let's talk philosophy maybe that's
something he should do
um
no i i guess i could tackle nietzsche
nietzsche is not someone i know that all
that much about so i don't you know i
would have to do a lot of research and
and so on
and the intersection between philosophy
and religion is very blurry and very you
know unclear a lot of times so
and like i said last time you know
considering like should i do a video on
platinus and neoplatonism since that
falls under the category of philosophy
rather than religion and then realizing
that you know it's my channel i can do
whatever i want
but also of course that those lines
between religion and philosophy is very
unclear sometimes and they
intersect or they cross over
into the the
into the other so to say
albano's sword what's your favorite
music to play do you play an
malmsteen do you mean the
guitarist in the mountain i'm not
that much into guitar music anymore i
used to be used to be a metalhead
essentially in in my teenage years
uh
i do play guitar i never sort of got
into that style of playing you know that
shredding
business
you know they're very talented
and i know a lot of really talented
victorious to do
shredding
i just that's just not the way i play
let's see
ah joseph the philosophy of black metal
you should like you should ask justin
about that he's a black metal guy
never actually even though i was a
metalhead
you know
back then i never got into black metal
too much i think i listened
to that one album by
the norwegian band what's their name
immortal is there a black battle bag
called immortal
they had this one album when i was
in that phase of my life that was pretty
cool but i never got that much into
black metal
pragmatic cobra
who's the best philosopher from anywhere
east or west in your opinion
obviously plato
no i don't know
uh
there are too many tutu to mention i
don't think there's one
our bonus toward what music do you play
i mean i play all kinds of music
not so much metal anymore i guess
since i kind of grew out of that i mean
i can still appreciate that stuff but i
just don't do that much anymore i think
i
you know metal is very
sort of
energetic and
angsty and angry a lot of the time and
i'm kind of not
i'm not very much that kind of person at
this point in my life
maybe
later on um i do play you know i do
still play what you could call like rock
music even though it's not metal music i
play
uh just the other day i had some friends
over and we played some
folk music i played the wood as some of
you know probably there i played the
odin my friends were playing you know
percussion stuff and the set of the
persians said taught and we just jam we
played like
folk music from the middle east i do
you know
background music to my videos
uh
i i i don't like to limit myself to any
one genre i i really enjoy exploring all
kinds of different
uh styles of music and also different
cultures of music
that's been one of the things i've done
and that's one of the things i do also
in in my what has been my main project
of music over the last like 10 years
which is a project called zeni
the whole purpose of which is basically
to explore different cultures musically
that is in different genres and try to
sort of have them meet in interesting
ways
you wanna there's some stuff
a lot of stuff that we did put out was
kind of rock and hard rock oriented but
it's also a lot more diverse than that
if you want to check it out it's the
name is zenith z so in zed
uh
i and i zini and that stuff's on spotify
and so on there's an album and then a
few singles that we put out
thank you hamad hassan for the
super chat and the donation thank you so
much i appreciate that
what gold dog asks you covered music in
islam yes
is there any other religion that you
would want to cover from the point of
music absolutely i think
that's always been one of my main
interests
which is natural perhaps because it
intersects or not it might like it's my
two well two of my main interests which
is religion and everything related to
that and then music which is another my
another one of my passions and so in
those places where those two subjects
meet of course that's something i'm
incredibly
interested in and so i would love to
explore you know music in different
hindu traditions or music and taoism is
a really
fascinating topic i love gucci music
so there's an instrument from china
called cochin which means ancient gene
so the actual instrument was called chin
it's spelled
let me put it like this
which i love that instrument and that
instrument is very strongly connected to
taoism and taoist philosophy
so that for example
is something that i would
love to explore more if only there was
time to
to do all of that
mr something football
and i football do you speak arabic just
a little bit i can read
arabic i studied arabic for a year
at university and then i had to
do some other stuff and i would i plan
on picking those studies up eventually
i do speak a little arabic
fosha only basically and a little bit of
like the iraqi
dialect because my uh
parts of my family are from iraq on my
wife's side
so but you know i'm not fluent i'm in
that basic
uh that classic position where i kind of
understand a lot if i'm hearing people
talk arabic i can understand a lot of
what they're saying but i can't really
speak
much myself and form sentences
uh
but i read for example
i've been reading uh
ibn adabi again i've been reading his
telugu
uh the famous collection of poetry and i
have this wonderful
translation by michael sells which came
out last year and that has which is the
perfect ev every book every translation
of a classic
work of literature should be in this way
that one page is the original language
so arabic and the other page is english
and that's just perfect and so i in
those circumstances i try to read the
arabic and try to appreciate the sort of
melody and the meter and the rhyming of
the actual poem and then when i feel
like i'm not understanding i can just
check the translation and you know it's
a great way of learning also
a lot of questions a lot of comments let
me see if i can pick one out here
i just realized i got really tired so
i'm not probably going to stream for
all that long but
i can hang out for a little while
yahoo what other languages are you
fluent in well i'm fluent basically in
english and swedish which is my native
tongue
i did study spanish in school for four
years
and
i couldn't
tell you
anything in spanish at this point i've
completely forgot it
although i had an interesting experience
the other day i was with a student
and i asked her i said just tell me
something in spanish and i'll see if i
understand it and she said this rather
long sentence in spanish
and i understood maybe like
50 of what she said
uh
and for the rest of the words
i made what i thought was a complete
guess like i was she said something
about you know uh
i don't even remember and i was like
that means and i thought i was being
silly i was like that means uh
grapes and i was correct so like every
word that i thought i was guessing i
actually got right even though i thought
it was a complete guess so somewhere way
back
in in my memory i still remember some of
that spanish but
i could not form
an advanced
sentence in that language
uva's that's right
yes musa i am i am swedish
i am from
from sweden
what religion are you personally that's
a question i get a lot of the time
i have answered that a lot of times or
sort of non-answered it a lot of times
uh
you know
i don't i don't
it's complicated i don't want to get
into too much i have answered that
question a little bit more in a previous
q a
i would say
um
have you ever been to morocco i was
going to go to morocco
back in december was my plan
but then you know kovid
came back
and i had to
cancel that trip but morocco is one of
those places that i wanted to go to for
a really long time and i hope to
to come there
soon
it's a natural place to go and when you
know considering the the stuff that i
study when it comes to sufism and all
that
so i need to go to morocco i really do
was the ibn albert poetry book called is
the tarjuman al-ashwach
which in
english is the interpreter of the
interpreter of desires or the translator
of desire sometimes
it's the book that
was supposedly inspired by ibn arabi
meeting this beautiful woman
called nizam
while he was in mecca
and there are references it seems to her
in the poetry uh and he did get some uh
he was critiqued for this
poetic work because to some it just
seemed like a collection of erotic
poetry um
but he insisted that you know this it's
all about god essentially um
and so to convince his critics he wrote
a commentary on each of the poems
explaining what each metaphor meant and
like yeah you know i talk about this
woman perhaps but i actually mean god or
it's a really fascinating book and it
has this incredible
section it has this poem poem number 11
which is the most famous of his poems
which is well poems aren't really named
so they're named after the first
line usually which is
which means oh doves of the arakan and
ban trees and and that line that poem
goes on eventually to culminate in this
really famous section
uh where he says you know my heart has
become capable of every form it is a
pasture for the gazelles it's a cloister
for monks it's
a house for pagans it's the kaaba for
the pilgrims
the scrolls of the torah and the pages
of the quran and then he says i
profess to the religion of love wherever
it's camels uh
go that is my religion and my faith
that's a very famous
poem and a really beautiful poem
sometimes misunderstood and
misrepresented as
meaning some kind of religious pluralism
or whatever which is not really what
he's saying but nonetheless it's an
incredible poem especially if you read
it in arabic with all the rhyming and so
on
and then he ends the poem he ends it not
with that which would be the perfect
place to end you know
i feel i follow the religion of love
it's you know that's my religion my
faith and then it goes on to just list a
bunch of famous lovers of history
um
like bish bisher and and hind and kaisen
leila
which is kind of an anticlimactic ending
to to a really beautiful poem but
nonetheless
apparently tardik thinks i'm looking
different today i haven't cut my hair in
a while i think
maybe
that's maybe that's it
my hair is longer than usual
see if there anymore
thank you for complimenting my arabic i
do my best
i've you know
i have been exposed to arabic for a
really long time
both through family relations but also
because even before i studied arabic
officially i was of course exposed to
arabic the arabic language through my
studies of islam and sufism
so you know arabic has been part of my
life for a long time
but i'm glad that people think i
pronounce things well
ayub what do you think the point of life
is
does anyone have an answer to that
question
i don't think so uh
you know i could
you know on on a better day when i'm not
this tired i would probably have some
very
philosophically based answered that
question but i
i feel like i'm
getting pretty tired let's but let's
talk
for a few more minutes
what do you think of so amin i mean what
do you think of sufism in
north africa i love that stuff and i
think that's been under underrepresented
in in scholarship and in public
discussions too um you know the
margherita in north africa and west
africa for that matter
is an incredibly
important
region for the development of sufism and
of course for sufism today
which is one of the reasons i wanted to
go to morocco of course and also one of
the reasons why i focused so much on
sufi is from that region so i did you
know even of course but he's really
famous but i did one on eben
i didn't
we're both from andalusia but sort of
that general region
for my
um both my bachelor's thesis and my
masters i focused on west african sufism
so the muridia brotherhood and the
tijaniya
which will be getting videos eventually
there's already one on the tijania but
the muridia is definitely getting run
pretty soon
going through the teachings of ahmadu
bamba who was the founder of that he was
a really
fascinating figure
who lived in the
well he died in 1927 so he was a pretty
recent figure and he was basically a
well he resisted french colonialism in
senegal but he did so
through
you know non-violent
means right a very strict
ideal of non-violence he
while some of his contemporaries of the
from the tijani order for example they
would of course resist the french
colonialists they will often do so uh
through a war right through um armed
struggle or armed you know jihad uh
jihad of the the sword
as opposed to what ahmadu bamba
taught which was the jihad of the pen
right so he wanted to
resist the french through educating the
the people his followers which was
primarily a religious education by
teaching them the quran and the sunnah
and those teachings according to him was
you know his interpretation of the
sunnah of the prophet muhammad for
example was one that was non-violent
and then he
created or this sufi order sufi
brotherhood
grew out of his teachings and his
movements which became known as the
muridia
which is one of the two
[Music]
biggest sufi orders in that region today
alongside the tijania and sufism
in west africa is incredibly
popular it's always widespread so
according to numbers at least back then
when i was doing my
field work
the numbers were something that you know
there are 90
what
is probably hyperbole let's say maybe
90 90
of senegal's population is muslim and
around like 95
let's say 90 again percent of those
muslims belong to a sufi brotherhood
right so the vast majority of people in
west africa are connected to sufism and
practice an islam that is colored by the
sufi tradition
which kind of reflects the way that
sufism
you know the relationship between
sufis and islam historically before it
became
for people who started to sort of
critique it and which was given less of
a role in society i think in west africa
is a really interesting example
a modern example of the kind of very
intricate and or very intimate
relationship
or intimate way that superism was part
of mainstream islam historically that i
think plays out in west africa today
that was a really long tangent what was
your question
anyway
see if there are any questions i missed
are you muslim
no
no
no i wouldn't say so
will you ever visit israel
i would like to i would like to
i have a complicated relationship with
the
political
situation there right
but
you know putting all that aside i would
love to visit because there's so much
history there and so much great culture
and people
um
i have friends there of course
one of whom
might still be watching
and so i would love to go to that region
as a student of religions you know
that's one of the
big
one of the the most major uh regions of
course
ivan yanovich thank you for the super
chat would you be open to exploring
vajrayana buddhism in more depth yes so
i'm i'm uh
i'm gearing towards
uh i'm gearing towards
putting out some content on buddhism
because pre
previously
still to some degree my knowledge on
that topic is relatively
limited compared to other traditions
that i've talked about
um
but now you know
i really want to put out some buddhism
content this year
i know that andrew from religion for
breakfast is do he's doing an amazing
series on buddhism right now
so you know
while you're waiting for my videos to go
check those out he just did one on pure
land buddhism which was amazing
so i'm gonna try to not
do the same videos that he's doing
because he's doing them so well um i
might be doing videos on
i'm probably doing a video on on
nagarjuna
a particular
philosopher i'm sure many of you are
familiar with he's one of the main
philosophers in the mahayana tradition
and the sometimes considered the founder
of the
it's madhyamaka it's the pronunciation
right the middle path essentially and
the
uh to some the father of the idea of
shunyata at least as formulated in later
buddhism this idea of
emptiness so i'm gonna do one on
nagarjuna and his text you know that
basic text that he he's
that which is the basis of that
philosophy i'm also gonna do videos on
tiantai buddhism
which is a chinese form or it's a form
of buddhism
from a mahayana buddhism that appeared
in china
later on which has a really interesting
and very rigorous and incredible
philosophical
tradition and idea of the so-called
three truths
so
mahayana buddhism through the influence
of nagarjuna often talks about the two
truths theory which is you know
conventional truth as we experience the
world and then the sort of deeper truth
of emptiness
and the tiantai philosophy affirms those
two but then there's a third truth in
the middle in which both of those are
sort of merged and it's incredible so i
want to do that i also want to do one on
um chan buddhism or zen buddhism i think
andrew is planning on about that though
but i might still
i might still do one
i gotta get to some of these super chats
here uh
sadiq thank you so much thoughts on said
hussain nasser and muhammad iqbal
i admire both of them very much
in asset is very important
currently for our understanding of a lot
of the
sufi traditions
like the school of ibn arabi you know
you know he's a really
important thinker an important
scholar in terms of that stuff and
i do like a lot of his ideas
um
he's part of the what's known as the
perennialist school they don't like that
term themselves
um
but uh you know i think a lot of those
ideas are appealing
to me it also is very interesting and
i'm probably doing a video on it while
eventually and i think he's a person
that i admire a lot too i lack a lot of
his perspectives on religion and
um and islam and you know
i think he was a very
he was one of the most major one of the
most interesting thinkers in the islamic
world of the 20th century and i'm going
to get to that in a video fully at some
point
thank you so much for the generous
donation
uh i saw one more elevator
says i bid higher amount on mahayana
buddhism
it's coming
mahayana
is coming definitely
why am i not muslim well i just i don't
know i just
i have never
i've never been convinced that
islam is
true to the
[Music]
is more true compared to other
religions necessarily to the point that
i feel like i can accept that as the
absolute truth
so
now you could of course
define muslim as a
you know the literal translation of that
word which is a person who submits to
the will of god or submits to god
i guess in some ways you could define me
as such but you know that would be a
lazy
and misleading
way to to deal with that question
um
thank you azad
hey philip are you familiar with a
pre-islamic middle east especially the
christian traditions figure
like john of damascus and else do you
have any sources sources not so much i
mean i could dig some up um
i am familiar with it though i did a
video on pre-islamic religion
in arabia um
which is a fascinating topic and it's
something that's a lot of the
information
is coming out very recently so we're
learning a lot of new things thanks to
scholarship by people like ahmed jalad
for example
who is coming at it from a different
angle also he is i think he's a linguist
originally right so he deals with
languages and scripts but through that
he's able to find some really
important
stuff that can teach us about the
culture and religion of ancient arabia
and one of the things we find of course
is that monotheism in the form of
christianity judaism
and may you know other forms of
monotheism perhaps or you know
more
basically that the situation in
pre-islamic reba was more complex than
many people at least
uh
assume
but then you know it's never even in the
original islamic sources things aren't
black or white you know islamic sources
that's interesting actually that a lot
of the findings that we we have now are
the things that are coming forth a lot
of that supports the original accounts
of some something you know someone like
ibn kalbi
who writes about the religion of
pre-islamic arabia
not all of it
syncs up but but you know it's it's uh
there isn't anything that has completely
shifted our perspective on it
but it's very interesting nonetheless to
to have more evidence conrad thank you
so much
for the super chat
do you have any reflections on how many
who come from mainland products and
traditions have in recent years been
converting to catholicism and orthodoxy
i have no idea
no idea actually
i have seen on youtube there has been
trends to that
you know like that people you know
talking about converting to
this or that you know catholicism
orthodoxy i have no idea about the
extent of that
so sorry but i can't really
can't really answer that question
uh ivan janovic again thank you so much
i think we're really fruitful to explore
madhyamika in more in depth
yes i'm also glad to be doing stuff on
that guys now because i think buddhism
people tend to think of buddhism just as
these monks meditating
but buddhism has one of the most
rigorous
philosophical systems or traditions in
history
and so i i really want to highlight some
of those amazing thinkers
from that tradition
a lot of super chats thank you guys so
much uh
of course i i'm going to prioritize the
super chats but i'm i'm going to try to
get to as many of your questions as
possible
i've been streaming for half an hour
yeah let's see how long i can go um
scale will thank you
so much
for the super chat
have you ever had any mystical
experience of your own if you're not if
not have you considered seeking it i did
uh recount one on such experience um in
the
live stream i did together with zevi and
justin just a few hours ago
and uh so you can go check that out on
the esoteric channel um
it's i've you you could say that i've
had experiences not that intense but you
know the stuff i've had has been
like all the classic stuff you know
you know the oneness or the you know
dissolution of
separate
identity and so on i've i've had
experience similar to that
um
of course with my sort of critical
academic mind
i tend to also think that you know part
of that is probably because i've already
been exposed to those kinds of ideas and
so my mind will suggest things but
um
still i've had some experiences that
have been quite powerful
definitely
for a more full uh
discussion on that you can check out
that live stream we did
but um again thank you uh what do you
think about uh krishnamurti
yeah i've always been so intrigued by
him and and
every time i've seen read anything by
him or seen him talk i think he's is you
know he's incredibly
charismatic
in a weird way
and just says the most fascinating stuff
and i i like a lot of his ideas i could
definitely make a video about him it's
not something that i've considered but
it's it's uh
maybe i should write that down but i
would have to
again
do more research
first
okay uh no one uh i said can you make a
video on the origins of salafism
that's actually the video i'm working on
right now uh primarily is a video about
salafism
which sort of it's basically you know
what is salafism so it talks about what
what that is when it originates
both in terms of modern salafism as we
know it today you know which emerges
primarily in the 20th and
20th and 20 no wait the 19th and 20th
centuries
uh but also tracing those ideas back
which you know it's true that salafism
to some degree is a modern
phenomenon a modern movement but a lot
of the tendencies and ideas that are at
the base of cytobism of course dates
back further back to figures like
even someone like you know wahab or even
taimiyah
some would even draw that even all the
way back to to someone like even hanbal
even though that you know
not everyone would agree with that but
so i try to cover the whole history and
the basic ideas of that movement
uh in a as comprehensive way as possible
so that
is either coming out next you know this
weekend or the next weekend we'll see i
might take this week off
because i've been doing a lot of
i've been working a lot lately and i
need to
i need to take breaks
candido junior
or jr radham thank you so so much for
the generous donation
metroid metro doris of lam pass
packets pack package lamp packers great
name thank you
also for the super chat do you have any
interest in ancient paganism nor is
celtic hellenistic
yeah and platinus and plato too yeah
i've just started this new series on on
religion and philosophy in the hellenic
world covered plato i'm doing one on on
the obsidian mysteries
uh you know norse stuff i want to do
that i think jackson crawford has that
covered really well
so check out his channel if you haven't
already he's an expert on
norse languages but it also deals a lot
with
the
religion
of the
ancient nordic people
in terms of plato and platinus you know
it's inevitable like i
it's inevitable that i'm gonna get to to
them
especially platinus because he's so
significant for all
i mean plato too
um and then platinus
after that is so central to the whole
history of
you know
religion too
uh really philosophy and and mysticism
primarily
uh
and tinus is probably one of my favorite
philosophers
not necessarily because i agree with
what he says
although i do i am drawn to a lot of his
ideas
a lot of the time but i think he's just
such a brilliant
brilliant thinker
and reading the any ads is a confusing
experience but also an incredibly
enlightening and interesting one
and his ideas of the one
and the sort of
elegant and simplified
interpretation that he gives on plato's
basic ideas i think is very
it's incredible i think it's incredible
and then you have people like yamblicus
who comes after him who
is very different even though he's
considered a neoplatonist you know
someone like yamblachus
has a very different
idea of some of the most basic
metaphysical concepts of platinus
and he's also really interesting so like
i want to do platinus i'm going to do
yum because
that whole
tradition is something that i will have
to cover and now that i've started the
series on on religion and philosophy in
the hellenic world that's a nice sort of
way in to start doing some of those
videos
brandon french thank you also for the
super chat
is there a linguistic
connection between this word sufi and
the wool codes used by the early
christian desert fathers that's kind of
the consensus
of scholars right
where does the word sufi come from
or to wolf which is the same root just
i forget what to saw with me and it's
something like
the way of becoming a sufi right or
something like that but anyway so sufi
the consensus or the opinion of the
majority of scholars is that the word
sufi comes from the arabic word suf
which means wool
referring to
the kind of clothing that the sort of
sufis proto-sufis would wear so of
course woolen
clothing and that's a renunciant way
and
you ask about the christian desert
fathers i think
also uh
what many scholars think is that the
early sufis were heavily inspired by
christian monasticism and asceticism in
particular
and so i think
there's definitely a connection there
even if it even if it is a an indirect
connection uh but in terms of the word
sufi linguistically probably comes from
wool from surf others say that it might
come from
you know sophia you know the greek word
for wisdom i think there's another one
that comes from
[Music]
the sofa which was a
group of people that lived in the time
of the prophet muhammad
who were the sort of elite group who
would
sort of hang out outside of the
prophet's mosque on a bench and so
they're called sofa the people of the
bench
and so the sufis sometimes will say that
these are the forefathers of the sufis
and that this name sufi comes from
sufa
but you know most people connected to
the word soof
so many questions uh
i promise i can be able to get to them
all i'm really sorry
uh
there okay elevator god is the only
reality so creation is a simulation
i think i'm skeptical of the simulation
thing i think that's a sort of egotistic
view at least if we understand
simulation theory based on sort of
in terms of like a computer simulation
that we're some sort of
simulation inside a computer built by
some other being out there i think
that's a very
um
egocentric world view to think that
something that we have created in
particular like computers and so on like
that would be
somehow the very basis of reality
uh
i don't know i don't i don't buy that
but there are other interpretations of
the word simulation that are i think it
could be more
proper
uh
let's see claudio eugenio
thank you so much also for the super
chat some scholars suggest wrote that on
the journey on his journeys sarah
thursday might
have met with the prophet daniel in
babylon and that he was his student for
a while would you consider a video about
that theory i've never heard about the
theory
if you know i could research that if i
find there to be a good uh
scholarly basis for it
then it could be worth making a video
about i think
all those old biblical prophets
very difficult to talk about because
there is
no evidence outside of the bible or the
quran also um
and so
yeah if i would talk about it would be
basically from the perspective of the
bible
and that would make it sort of a
theological
channel or theological video in a way
but i guess there are other ways of
doing that too
um
maybe yeah so i mean the the ancient
prophets of israel or you know the
biblical prophets is a really
interesting topic
in general and i i was thinking about
that i think yesterday that i like
it would be fun to make videos about
those
really interesting characters who have
been so
central
to the history of religion
rachel thank you thank you so much
um
just really nice sentiment and uh thank
you for the compliment thank you so much
i appreciate all of you
and your kind comments and the support
that you all give that's uh
it really inspires me to
to do a lot of this work
it's inspiring enough because it's such
an interesting topic but
knowing
that there's an audience out there who
who enjoys it makes it even more
worthwhile
sadik
again sadiq amir thank you do you have
any advice for making video essays
basing it on my own
pre-written form of essays
i mean yeah you can i mean the simplest
way is you could just record yourself
either reading the essay or sort of
rewriting the essay to fit more into a
sort of video form a more accessible way
and then just reading it and you know
you could use
images
and video there's like wikimedia commons
for example which is a good source to
find images that are under a creative
commons license
you should still credit them if you're
if it's like photos and stuff but at
least then you'll know that you're
allowed to use them
and then there are like services like
storyblocks or shutter stock like stock
footage
services which you have to pay a monthly
fee usually but um
yeah just like start up recording stuff
either just your voice or maybe you can
film yourself
one advice i should give is that
sound quality is often a lot more
important than video quality you can
have a terrible video
quality and your mic sounds good and
that's a lot more i think that's
preferable to having
a really professional camera and then
terrible sound i don't know if you guys
agree but i i tend to think that
that's a general rule um so like record
yourself and uh
just just play around with with uh with
visuals with images with try to sort of
convey what you're saying through visual
means either text or through images
and i think you know if you have
something interesting to say people will
listen
uh
even if it's just like
if there are no visuals it was just like
one image for half an hour i know a lot
of people who do those kinds of videos
as long as what they're saying is
interesting there are people who will
listen so
just
get out there and
produce
content
uh spit wings thank you so much for the
donation
i appreciate all of you who support me
in any way both you know monetarily like
that but also just like i said just
supporting through your nice comments
and and so on i have to sneeze
no i don't
uh ivan janovic again thank you thank
you thank you thank you uh i think it
would be prove beneficial to explore
ornament of the middle way by mitham
rinpoche if you haven't done so yet it's
an astonishing work i haven't read that
i don't know if i've ever heard about
that is that a buddhist work if so then
that probably tells you a lot about my
relative lack of experience with
buddhism but thank you for the
suggestion i'll keep that in mind
okay so no more super chats i missed
right
no there are more super chats okay
uh let's see
yes here we go
fares thank you for the super chat can
you explain the judaism how was jesus
with jewish professing god when judaism
doesn't acknowledge either
how did god give them the land when they
don't believe in god i'm not sure i i
get your question
who are you saying the jews didn't
believe in god
because that seems
wrong
it seems like a pretty central part of
judaism
can you explain the judaism how was
jesus jewish i mean jesus was jewish
that's you know
very few people
will dispute that and understanding
jesus means understanding his jewish
context and his you know his jewish
identity
then of course
you could argue when christians do argue
that he
his message was one that some
something we departed from judaism or
it did eventually become its own thing
but there's no denying that he
as you know was a jew
who lived in and worked and preached in
a jewish environment to jews
do how was jesus jewish professing god
when judaism i mean
so you seem to be saying that judaism
doesn't acknowledge god but judaism does
acknowledge god
i don't see any other
perspective on that so i don't know
how else to answer that question
azad
good name i've actually uh
have a little group of friends we play
um
we play sort of folk music like middle
eastern folk music um and we're actually
called azad so i like that name uh
anyway thank you for the super chat
please consider like doing a video about
the critics of islam like
and then ma'ari would yes
someone especially that i want to do a
video on
and there are a lot of misconception
about him you know he was an atheist or
that he was
uh
you know completely anti-religion i mean
he you know judging from his poetry he
was pretty pious he was a very pious
individual
although he did criticize
religion
as it
existed in society a lot of the time it
was critical and satirical against um
so al-mari is a arabic poet who lived in
i want to say 10th century right
and he is famous for you know being
vegetarian or vegan essentially
which is kind of anachronistic i guess
but um
but also he's often seen as an atheist
and that's not really true although he
was often a critic of a lot of the
religious institutions of the time like
the way that
certain aspects of islam functioned in
society and so on
and he's also a really great poet a lot
of his poetry is really beautiful so
i'm
out of someone i
definitely want to do a video on
so no one
asks about rashid
he's important for the development of
modern salafism i guess there are a lot
of different things that that come
together to form what we know as modern
salafism but um
he comes from that reform movement
reform
you know based on people like al frany
and muhammad abdul in the 19th century
and you know they were
you know rashid rita eventually departed
a lot from those people and became a lot
more close to
people like
i've been telling me uh perhaps inspired
by people like even say me and even
after wahab to some degree i guess
much more critical to western influence
and western modernity whereas abdul and
alefkrani were a lot more
willing to to meet
that at least in in a more comprehensive
way
uh
i mean i don't need to
go through the whole life of rashid but
he's he's an interesting figure he comes
up in my upcoming video about salavism
he's not a central figure in that video
but he comes up
because he's important in that
development
i saw some super chats
thank you sadik
i'm glad my advice was
i hope my advice was somewhat helpful
now site
is there any other music video i really
like the first one
you mean music video as in videos about
music as in like sufi music
um yeah like i said earlier i do want to
do more videos about music in different
religious traditions like taoism for
example
and sufi music will come up again
maybe we'll dive into particular aspects
of that like the mev levy
sama for example
or
you know different you know different
you're just diving deeper into
particular expressions of sufi music
music and
you know the indian subcontinent or
whatever
but not just super symbols i want to do
music in other traditions i don't know
as much about that you know focus so
much on my studies over the years on
sufi music
that you know that video was a lot of
fun like i said in my earlier livestream
i was pretty nervous making that because
it was like a topic that i'm very
passionate about
but it was a lot of fun
and something that i already had a lot i
had like basically already done a lot of
research over the years
and i just had to sort of gathered all
of those years of study and experience
into that one video so that was a really
sort of central video for me
where i got to
display some of
[Music]
some of my
[Music]
you know i was gonna use the word
expertise but i sound that sounds
pompous but i guess i do have a certain
level of expertise on that topic and i
it felt good to to have a video where i
can talk about something that i'm
you know that i've studied so much
claudio again thank you thank you
this text gives suggestions about
zarathustra's lifetime anyone would ah
so thank you for the for the link
search dress is fascinating i have a
video about the rationalism on the
channel
but that's like the only video on that
topic which is strange because i love
zoroastrianism and i would love to do
more about that
again if there only was time
if i had an infinite amount of time to
do all this stuff than i would
okay but um
thank you again then i gotta get to some
of the non-super chat questions too so
you guys don't feel left out are you
interested in talking about the
connection between
krishnamurti alan watts terence mckenna
yeah
all these sort of contemporary stuff and
the psychedelic
movement and all that how that connects
to different mystical traditions
also inevitable that i will get to that
at some point
there is a lot of interesting parallels
that we can draw on sort of on the at
least how people
talk about the experiences they have
while on for example psychedelics you
know someone like terence mckenna
and
you know mystics in history
i think we should be careful not to draw
too many parallels there but it's an
interesting topic
it's a controversial topic and i don't
want it to seem like i condone you know
the use of
substances like that but um
i think
we need also to have those conversations
a lot more we need to get rid of a lot
you know the stigma around even talking
about that stuff because there is a lot
of
what seems like really important stuff
a lot of important discussions to be had
about those topics
[Music]
okay
so uh king's chamber i hope you make
serious and i wanna stuff i have a video
in hana
uh two years ago i think
from january 2020 i think is the video
it's pretty short you know they deserve
a lot more than a short video but
there's one video about the
safa
um david wilson so a non-super chat
david wilson have you ever read the the
zohar or or the bahir
and what are your thoughts on them i
have not read the zohar
i have considered buying the uh
the 12 volume translation by
i forget i forget the name there's a 12
volume translation of the zohar
which i
have not i haven't gotten i remember
read parts of the zohar in different
quotes and so on
um but i haven't read it actually it
seems like a really difficult text
but at some point yes the
pritzker edition that's right thank you
david
what do you think of the theory that the
burning bush was an acadia tree which
contains dmt
i know that's a very
popular theory these days
i'm not i'm not discarding it but i'm
skeptical of all that stuff
uh
i think we should uh
i don't think we should search
we shouldn't read scripture that
literally i think
i think we should it's like the ancient
alien thing and like
look at this painting from the 1400s
there's a spaceship
it's like it's not a spaceship it's you
know
sort of people who forget how art works
and in this case i feel like
we should be careful not to forget how
literature works and how people express
themselves especially in those kinds of
texts
not that everything should be read
metaphorically but
i think
we should be careful not to search too
much for those kinds of
[Music]
naturalistic or or
literal interpretations or try to find
some sort of
scientific answers to to something that
is supposed to be
a miracle of some sort
it could of course be a metaphor for the
mt experience i guess but i you know
i don't i don't buy that stuff
personally you know i haven't been
convinced of those theories but you know
all theories are
have a place and all theories are
welcome
i think it's healthy to to have people
propose different ideas about stuff like
that but personally i don't
i'm not convinced by that stuff
so there are a lot of interesting
questions here
the neon cicada do you feel like that
psychedelic substances and religious
settings negate the legitimacy of those
experiences i don't think so
necessarily
again i should be careful with my words
here because i don't want to make it
sound
like i'm saying something
problematic but i think
you know an experience is an experience
i think
i don't know if there's necessarily that
much of a difference between a sort of
powerful religious or mystical
experience
reached through
[Music]
you know non-substance means and
something that can be reached through
something like a substance
although with that said i think
using substances can be can be
more dangerous perhaps because it
it's sort of a shock
it's a very sudden experience rather
than something that you've worked
towards and built towards and i know a
lot of people also that have those kinds
of experiences
and
which we talked about like zebby pointed
out really well in our live stream that
the whole point becomes about this
experience
rather than
what that experience can
and what meaning that experience can
have for our life afterwards how that
can transform
our lives and the way we behave and the
way we relate to people around us and
the world and our ethics and so on um
i think
many people tend to get stuck in
especially when it comes to
substances like that people get stuck in
just the experience itself
and don't sort of progress beyond that
but that's just my kind of
those are just my thoughts
have i mean i've studied sufism for many
years i've done field work in my
academic career in my earlier studies
and of course i've met with sufis i have
participated in sufi
gatherings i have met with the shaykhs
in different circumstances yes
i think
for me at least that's important if
you're studying a topic like that at
least if you're really like studying it
like
like you you want to make that your
expertise or whatever i think it's
important to
um
to talk and not only to talk to the
people who actually practice it and to
you know who are part of that tradition
so that they can
speak not just read books by
outsiders and and talk to outsiders but
to talk to those people but also to sort
of
at least in some way
experience
that setting
um
so for example to to to participate in
the sufi gathering gives you another
perspective on on those kinds of rituals
and those kinds of experiences even if
you can never
fully
grasp it in the way that an insider
would unless you actually sort of
go native as they say and
join the group so to say but i think
it's important
as a scholar to
to try to engage directly with with the
traditions that we're studying
so i have
i've met
sheikhs or
in plural
which have you know
really
impressive people a lot of you know at
least those people that i met really
sort of inspiring and
just
especially when i started the jania
i'm not going to name any names but i
did go on a pilgrimage with the tijunia
to a village in
in bogal which is a village in southern
senegal and their their sort of leader
resided there and i met him and i was
there and he just had this incredible
just they have this incredible aura this
grace around them you know
one of the things i studied in my
masters was the way that this kind of
authority is created through different
means but even though you're sort of
deconstructing it you can't deny that
there is
you know there's a presence
to a lot of those people
that's really interesting
jacob thinks i i seem tired i am a
little tired
um i should be
you can my voice is cracking up i should
i should end the stream pretty soon but
i think it's so much fun to talk to you
guys so
sadik uh
if you could travel back in time and
spend the day as a fly on the wall any
time period an area of the world where
you want to i ca i've gotten this
question before i can't
answer properly because i would just
want to go everywhere at every time
i would love to
you know check out what what jesus was
doing or the prophet muhammad and the
buddha and because i studied religion i
think those are sort of the given
answers but really anything
is
would be interesting
it's really hot in here too uh i'm going
to like just a few more questions and
then i'll
aerodynamism is there an entry level
literature and even out of there kind of
isn't
there is no one book that i think goes
through it
in in
[Music]
in a way that sort of is a good entry
level i think the best way to
to approach someone like a bananabe is
to read a lot of different literature i
told this to one of my patrons in our
discord chat
i think the best way to to um
to approach that is to just read a lot
of different
books stuff like by scholars you know
like with him chidik or whatever um
but also primary sources or read
books by ibn adams
himself and followers of his school
and then eventually gradually
things will start to fall into place you
know by reading all of these different
accounts
i don't think there's one book that does
that at least not in that
case
okay
you know what guys i'm probably gonna
have to call it there
i need to get some
i need to wind down and to get some
sleep
i've been streaming for an hour so
that's pretty good
uh but thank you all for showing up
thank you for those of you who
who joined me and zevian justin for
joined livestream earlier and thank all
of you of course now who shot up here
it's always a pleasure and
so much fun to talk to you guys sorry to
those of you that who i didn't get the
opportunity to answer your questions i
tried to get to as many of you as
possible
and i also had to to prioritize these
super chats of course as i'm sure you
understand
thank you so much guys uh good night i
hope you have a wonderful
day a wonderful week
and i'll see you in a future video the
next one is probably the one on salafism
and
also i look forward to doing more live
streams so thank you so much
good night
and bye